[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais donc partager mon interprétation
le 4 octobre dernier la nouvelle
calédonie à voter sur son avenir avec ou
sans la france et pour la deuxième fois
le nom à l'indépendance l'a emporté avec
53,26 % alors qu'il était à 56 points 4
au premier vote la participation a été
de 84 72% du collège électoral spécial
qui est de 180 1640 votants à comparer
avec celui du suffrage universel qui lui
est de 215 me il est important d'en
comprendre les conséquences et les
solutions à apporter
car après le troisième référendum en
2022 on risque d être trouble très grave
en cas de victoire du non où de perdre
une part significative de notre espace
maritime et de notre présence dans cette
région du monde
en cas de victoire du oui
comment en est on arrivé là découverte
par le navigateur anglais james cook en
1774 la nouvelle calédonie a été
proclamée colonie française en 1853 et
11 ans après on a ouvert le premier
bagne qui était moins dure qu'en guyane
du fait des conditions climatiques parce
qu'on y faisait de l'agriculture ont
validé porté jusqu'en 1897
de nombreux condamnés dont la plupart
devant rester sur place après la fin de
leur condamnation selon les lois de
l'époque exploiteront des terres prises
au kanak
ils formeront la plus grande partie de
la population blanche qu'on appelle les
caldoches on y enverra aussi en 1873 les
déportés de la commune dont la célèbre
louise-michel it la vierge rouge qui
après deux ans de bagne s'y installera
comme institutrice pour les français les
kanak avant de rentrer en france en 1881
nick des portes aura enfin les kabyles
après la révolte de 1872 qui deviendront
citoyens français contrairement à ceux
restés en algérie parallèlement dès la
fin du 19e siècle
la nouvelle qu'elle est devenue une
colonie de peuplement avec l'arrivée de
paysans français qui cherchait des
terres et de travailleurs venus d'asie
la plupart de ces derniers venaient
travailler dans des conditions très
dures dans les mines de la société le
nickel qui représentait alors 40% de la
production mondiale
aujourd'hui l'île est peuplée de 270
mille personnes dont 39% de canac 30% de
caldoches et le reste de migrants venus
des îles du pacifique où des
métropolitains qu'on appelle là-bas les
oreilles
elle est découpée en trois régions et
villes loyauté composée quasi totalement
de canac la province nord avec une large
majorité de kanaks et la province hugh
est la plus riche avec une majorité
caldoche et la capitale nouméa les
kanaks qui vivaient dans l'île avant
l'arrivée des colonies
sont un peuple d'agriculteurs avec une
forte culture coutumière d'attachement à
la terre au nombre de 45 milles environ
en 1850
ils ont été parqués dans des réserves
comme les indiens d'amérique du nord
avec un statut d'indigène qui sera
abolie par le général de gaulle en 1946
décimée à plus de 50% par la maladie et
le changement de vie c'est canal vont
être aidés et protégé par les
missionnaires puis par le parti
communiste qui va les encourager à
revendiquer dans les années 1950 comme
le rappelle l'anthropologue michel hmaé
pence
l'union calédonienne qui était composé
de kanaks et d'européens vivent dans la
bouche a obtenu que le territoire est à
côté du haut commissaire le représentant
du gouvernement
un conseil de gouvernement et une
assemblée générale locales dotées de
pouvoirs spécifiques et en 1957 s'est
tenue la première élection au suffrage
universel et juste pour mémoire il faut
signaler qu'il faudra attendre 1962 pour
avoir un premier bachelier kanak
la situation va se dégrader dans les
années 60 la france qui se rend compte
de l'intérêt stratégique du nickel dont
la calédonie détient 25% des ressources
mondiales est confrontée à la volonté
indépendantistes des kanaks qui veulent
récupérer leurs terres
en réponse pour garder la majorité
électorale
les français vont encourager
l'immigration de réfugiés pieds noirs
ayant quitté l'algérie puis d'une
population venue de france et surtout
des territoires d'outre-mer ensuite en
1984 le statut lemoine va accorder une
autonomie accrue aux territoires mais
sur une base électorale qui inclut tous
les habitants de l'île et c'est le début
une opposition de plus en plus violente
qui va durer 4 le leader kanak jean
marie tjibaou va regrouper les
indépendantistes et parti
indépendantiste ou les groupes
indépendantistes dans le fln grèce en
1984 et créer un gouvernement provisoire
de canettes et la crise atteindra son
niveau maximal en avril 1988 avec tout
le monde s'en souvient la sphère de la
grotte d'ouvéa
après l'assassinât de quatre gendarmes à
l'armé blanche place aux par les
parachutistes et les gendarmes pour
délivrer les otages se soldera par 19
kanaks tué et deux militaires après ce
drame tout le monde est conscient qu'il
faut trouver une solution
le gouvernement socialiste michel rocard
qui veut apaiser la situation pour
pouvoir organiser une évolution
concertée vers l'indépendance négocié
les accords de matignon fin 1988
on peut noter qu'ils se feront avec
l'aide de la franc maçonnerie dont font
partie localement le chef du camp anti
indépendantistes le caldoche jacques
lafleur et le chef des indépendantistes
le kanak jean marie tjibaou et ajoutons
le nombre de leurs conseillers
ces accords prévoient une période de
transition de 10
un rééquilibrage économique de l'île
entre les régions sud et nord puis un
référendum d'autodétermination ne
concerne que les habitants ayant plus de
dix ans de résidence à la date du
scrutin
à l'échéance les signataires ont
constaté que le territoire n'était pas
prêt à voter sans risquer de rebasculer
dans la violence et ils ont alors décidé
de renégocier le 5 mai 1998
roch wamytan successeur de jean marie
tjibaou qui a été assassiné en 1988 par
un opposant le kanak va être avec
jacques lafleur et le premier ministre
lionel jospin
les principaux signataires des accords
de nouméa
ceux-ci reconnaissant que les kanak ont
été colonisés veulent aboutir à une
forme de souveraineté
fondée sur un destin comme ils
garantissent la coexistence entre ce
qu'ils vivent depuis toujours sur place
et les caldoches en excluant tous ceux
qui sont arrivés après 1994 et à la fin
de ces accords à la fin des accords de
nouméa
il est prévu de réaliser 3 référendum
successifs sur l'autodétermination en
cas de vote contre l'indépendance c'est
à dire que dès qu'il ya un vote pour
l'indépendance ça s'arrête
mais si jamais les gens veulent
continuer à rester français on bascule
et ont fait un autre vote
ceci montre que le gouvernement de
l'époque dans son anti colonialisme a
clairement choisi d'aller à
l'indépendance en contournant le vote
coudray qui déclencherait la violence le
problème c'est que pour jacques lafleur
aujourd'hui et spa où le sénateur pierre
frogier qui aura plus tard le nid des
courageuses de mettre ensemble les
drapeaux français et kanak sur le
fronton des mairies
il s'agit de demeurer dans la république
dans le cadre de relations nouvelles
mais pour les autres comme repos à mi
temps élu deux fois depuis comme
président du congrès où paul néaoutyine
l'actuel président de la province nord
c'est le premier pas vers une
indépendance qui commence à se
construire
en définitive leur seul point
véritablement comme un son attachement à
cette terre
des deux côtés et la référence à
l'article sens de la charte du peuple
kanak qui parle de souveraineté partagée
pour le vote d'autodétermination réservé
aux habitants d'avant 94 la définition
du corps électoral exclu 20% de la
population ce qui est totalement
contraire au suffrage universel
république
il a cependant été validés par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme il
favorise les kanaks dont les familles
ont un taux de fécondité bien supérieur
aux caldech ce qui leur permet d'avoir
de deux à quatre mille voix de plus à
chaque référendum
mais cet artifice qui peut leur faire
gagner mathématiquement le troisième
référendum avec le temps qui passe ne
change pas la réalité
comme le rappelle jean yves fabre ont
dans le monde du 26 septembre
si l'on oublie ceux qui sont exclus du
vote et sont majoritairement contre
l'indépendance
les deux blocs sont de poids comparable
et aucun ne peut exclure l'autre
de plus il faut ajouter que la
population métissée et des deux côtés
tandis que certains caldoches sont pour
l'indépendance et certains kanak pourra
ces français comme le signale guillaume
tabard dans le figaro du 3 octobre la
tente d'un autre référendum risque de
nous faire assister un durcissement des
positions des uns et des autres dans un
pays coupé en deux au plan ethnique et
géographique entre ceux qui veulent
rester français dans la province sud et
les autres du nord et des îles qui
veulent l'indépendance
pourtant il faudra toute façon de vivre
ensemble au lieu de chercher des
arguments introuvable pour faire gagner
clairement son camp l'heure n'est-elle
pas au dialogue pour concevoir un projet
commun
à l'ensemble des signataires des accords
de nouméa nouvelle calédonie a la chance
d'avoir des dirigeants politiques des
deux bords et des conseillers qui sont
expérimentés se fréquence et connaissent
parfaitement la situation
ne faut-il donc pas aller vers une
solution intermédiaire permettant une
évolution du statut qui serait alors
l'objet du troisième référendum et ne
ferait ni gagnant ni perdant
comme l'a dit le président macron
commentant les résultats
il s'agit de dépasser l'histoire
coloniale de l'archipel français et
construire ensemble la nouvelle
calédonie de demain
soyons clairs les vieux réflexes anti
colonialiste
selon lequel le peuple kanak serait
aujourd'hui encore repris mais sont loin
de répondre à la réalité locale comme le
dit justement emmanuel tjibaou
dans une tribune du 16 septembre il faut
sortir de l'imposture intellectuelle
réduisant l'analyse de la situation
calédonienne à l'existence d'un système
colonial institutionnalisé en affirmant
que la réflexion doit être guidée par
une éthique de vérité il faut avoir le
courage de la nuance et refuser les
stéréotypes pour embrasser la réalité
qu'elle est de nien depuis les accords
de matignon ce pays a changé
le développement s'est réorienté la
répartition budgétaire entre les
provinces a été rééquilibrée et les
compétences administratives étatiques
ont été transférés en dehors bien sûr
des domaines régaliens
il faut donc réfléchir à partir de la
réalité actuelle
ce qui n'est pas facile car les deux
camps se sont beaucoup engagé auprès de
leurs électeurs et dirigeants
indépendantistes craignent les réactions
du jeunesse kanake souvent violente qui
a idéalisé les vertus de la dépendance
tandis que les loyalistes craignent les
réactions très dur dès caldoches de la
brousse sur une terre qui est aussi la
leur il faut donc que chacun mette ses
cartes sur la table en cas
d'indépendance de la nouvelle calédonie
les dispositions constitutionnelles
transitoire la régissant devront être
retirées l'ensemble des fonctions
régaliennes assurée par l'administration
française devons être reprise par les
locaux dans un délai à fixer d'état
français continuera-t-il à verser 175
milliards pour aider au développement du
territoire et sous quelle forme
c'est peu probable
si l'on en juge par ce qu'il attribue
aux anciens territoires français ayant
pris leur indépendance dans l'intérêt
général de tous les calédoniens et de
tous bords l'état français doit prendre
une position claire et sans ambigüité
afin qu'ils aillent aux urnes pour le
prochain vote en toute connaissance de
cause
certes il y aura les pan dentiste avance
que la baisse du niveau de vie ne sera
pas un problème et se compare au vanuatu
qui a été abandonné par les anglais mais
ils oublient que les chinois sont en
train de mettre la main sur ces îles qui
sont devenus un pays du tiers-monde
en dehors de quelques coutumier
d'asiatiques deux oreilles où l'on
régler leurs comptes avec la france ce
n'est pas le souhait d'une partie
importante des kanaks et de la quasi
totalité des autres habitants de l'est
que se passera-t-il quand le retour
légales et obligatoires au suffrage
universel
après la fin des accords de nouméa
montrera que la majorité est toujours
contre l'indépendance
dans tous les cas de figure d'un
nouvelle calédonie doit faire face à un
problème économique majeur pour qu'un
pays accédant à l'indépendance puisse
maintenir son niveau de vie
il faut que sa production intrinsèque et
ses exportations l'ua sur les ressources
suffisantes pour sa balance des
paiements ce fut le cas de l'afrique du
sud de l'inde
mais malheureusement pas le cas pour les
territoires à colonie française en
dehors de certains pays d'afrique qui
avait déjà des ressources internes
industriels et des richesses minières
comme la côte d'ivoire n'étant pas
autosuffisants le territoire est obligé
d'importer la plus grande partie de ses
besoins ce qui impacte le coût de la vie
de plus il ne peut compter sur un
tourisme il faut bien le dire ne marche
pas vraiment en dépit de la beauté des
paysages et des conditions
environnementales et climatiques
contrairement à d'autres villes du
pacifique qui ont réussi à gagner
l'option tourisme en calédonie
l'essentiel des exportations vient de
l'exploitation des mines de nickel qui
sont les principaux employeurs du
territoire mais ce minerai dont les
chinois sont les plus gros acheteurs à
des cours fluctuant en fonction de la
demande et des stocks
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une phase
de forte rentabilité
après plusieurs années de lourdes pertes
les mines de nouvelle calédonie sont
exploités par trois sociétés dont la sln
la société du nickel qui fait partie de
l'histoire sociale et économique du
territoire
les accords de nouméa ont permis dans un
but de rééquilibrage économique de créer
dans la province nord une société
d'exploitation de l'énorme gisement de
nickel du koniambo malheureusement
lusine dessinée à transformer le minerai
pour apporter de la valeur ajoutée à la
province nord est loin d'avoir donné les
résultats attendus
elle a créé plus d'endettement de
profits d'autant que la plus grande
partie du minerai est dorénavant
transformer en corée en province sud
lusine classique de la sln implanté
depuis toujours dans la banlieue de
nouméa avec les problèmes que ça peut
poser a survécu
derrière crise grâce à des prêts et des
aides de l'état les brésiliens de vale
ont construit plus au sud une usine
moderne utilisant l'hydrométallurgie qui
permet de traiter une gamme plus élargie
du minerai mais elle a eu de gros
problèmes de pollution chimique ne
donnant pas encore les résultats
attendus cette usine qui est mise en
vente par son propriétaire qui se
recentre et réoriente sa stratégie
industrielle
c'est évidemment un moment opportun pour
remettre à plat la gestion de la plus
grande richesse du territoire en mettant
autour de la table les industriels et
l'état pour construire une solution
commune rationnelle tout en empêchant
certains de saboter les négociations des
autres ne faut-il pas avoir un seul site
industriel dans le sud qui regrouperait
valais et la sln en transférant celle-ci
nouméa d'autant qu'au-delà de la
réorganisation de la production
industrielle et de la gestion des
activités minières
il faut optimiser l'utilisation des
ressources et des réserves en pensant à
l'avenir il faut améliorer les
compétences locales pour garder le
contrôle de la situation
il faut préserver l'environnement et
faire réellement bénéficié le territoire
des retombées économiques
enfin n'oublions pas que là où il ya du
nickel il ya du cobalt or vous le savez
bien les métaux rares prennent de plus
en plus de valeur face à la demande
mondiale
et c'est donc une autre ressource
minière potentiels pour la nouvelle
calédonie
en conclusion cette analyse rapide et
comme l'écrit justement pierre
bretegnier sur son site facebook
chacun comprend qu'une solution durable
ne pourra s'imposer que si l'adversaire
trouvera des raisons suffisantes à la
faire en s'appuyant sur la volonté de
vivre durablement ensemble c'est tout
l'enjeu des négociations étant entendu
que l'indépendance et l'association sont
totalement antinomiques
toute analyse sur la vie dans laquelle
est denis se conclut sur quatre options
stratégiques
le maintien dans la france avec un
statut d'autonomie comme tahiti dans
lequel l'évolution par rapport à la
situation actuelle concernera la
délimitation des compétences régulier
l'indépendance qui devra fixer dans le
temps les modalités de transfert de la
souveraineté aux nouveaux pays et les
moyens d'accompagnement mises en oeuvre
en y incluant la possibilité d'y garder
une base militaire et navales la
partition en deux pays
la province sud d'un côté et celle du
nord les îles loyauté de l'autre qui
pourrait ou non être associé en
s'appuyant sur les votes au référendum
alors cette solution qu'on dit
pratiquement impossible il faut rappeler
que c'est celle qui a été pratiquée par
l'otan en serbie avec le kosovo
c'est celle qui a été pratiquée en
ukraine par la russie avec la crimée et
c'est celle qu'on pratiquait les
français aux comores avec mayotte
enfin la quatrième c'est le choix
intermédiaire préconisée par florence et
jean yves fabre ont dans leur livre sur
les fédéralisme et la nouvelle calédonie
pour eux le fédéralisme l'introduction
politique de la décentralisation au plan
administratif et nous en avons un
exemple réussi par les îles cook avec la
nouvelle zélande qui n'est pas loin le
maintien dans la france où
l'indépendance déboucheront forcément
soit des troubles importants créé par
les pertes il n'ya donc de vraies
solutions permettant de vivre ensemble
avec ses différences dont une préserve
l'unité du territoire au delà des
représentants politiques locaux
il faut que l'état cesse de jouer le
rôle de spectateur pour s'engager
vraiment en faisant évoluer les
positions des protagonistes
espérons que la raison des uns et des
autres l'emportera pour le bien de tous
à bientôt
[Musique]